[Musique]
pour parler de réinventer les codes
je me suis dit ouais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui ils sont tombés sur
quelque chose d'important
ils sont tombés sur quelque chose
d'important parce que j'ai beaucoup
voyagé on se pose souvent la question
dans les pays en voie de développement
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'est pas là
pourquoi est-ce qu'on va pas ceci est
quelque part je pense que de toutes les
expériences que j'ai eu un des points
clés que j'ai vu c'est l'innovation
partout dans le monde les populations
les peuples qui sont les meilleurs sont
des gens qui sont constamment en train
de réinventer constamment en train de
penser de créer demain
et quelque part participé aux fêtes de
développer cet état d'esprit dans le
pays
j'ai trouvé ça séduisant c'est pour ça
que je suis là aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
un cours magistral je vous donnerai
jusqu'à une de mes expériences quelques
j'aurai quelques exemples qui ont aidé à
forger des convictions parce que
finalement ce que je veux partager
aujourd'hui ce sont quelques convictions
les convictions que je veux partager
aujourd'hui sont que au niveau d'une
d'une entreprise au niveau d'un pays au
niveau d'un individu réinventer c'est
faire des choix
réinventer c'est choisir soit de prendre
la voie normale
la voix conseillé par les parents soit
de choisir la voie conseillé par les
proches par la sagesse populaire soit de
prendre une porte différente une porte
vers un nouvel avenir une porte vers un
nouvel horizon et de prendre le risque
d'ouvrir cette porte
j'ai en 1955 une expérience personnelle
je n'étais pas né un jour assure mais
mon père venait d'avoir le bepc faut
savoir que mon grand père était tailleur
et quand il a eu le bepc toute la
famille a dit bon toi tes études là
c'est bon ça finisse devient instituteur
et puis tu vas commencer à nous donner
de l'argent mais lui l'a dit non je veux
aller plus loin parce que je pense que
les études c'est important c'est ce qui
va me permettre d'aller plus loin et la
décision est venue au niveau de mon père
qui est ailleurs a aucune étude etc
il a dit bon écoute et c'est lui qui est
parti là bas s'il dit qu'il faut aller
plus loin il faut l'écouter il sait ce
qu'il fait et bien mon père a pu grâce à
ça allait continuer ses études faire une
école de commerce
en europe devenir un des cadres dans le
café cacao de la côte d'ivoire des
années soixante dix je ne serais pas là
aujourd'hui je n'aurais pas eu le
parcours que j'ai aujourd'hui
si je n'avais pas eu cette base dans la
vie parce qu'à un moment donné il a
choisi une porte différente donc la
première étape la première conviction
c'est que pour entreprendre
il faut de temps en temps faire des
choix différents sortir des sentiers
battus donc je vous incite à le faire la
deuxième chose que j'ai envie de
partager avec vous c'est de dire qu' un
individu se construit de son parcours de
ceux de sa vie des personnes qu'il a
rencontrées au niveau professionnel mais
il ne faut pas que nous soyons défini à
100% par cet environnement là nous
devons être capables de prendre ce que
cet environnement nous offre et à un
moment donné et c'est ce qui constitue
l'individu d'être capable d'en faire une
synthèse et de dépasser de transcender
cet environnement j'ai eu la chance
jusqu'à 18 ans et je ne l'échangerais
pour jamais pour rien au monde de
grandir dans ce beau pays qu'est la côte
d'ivoire à une époque où il y avait
aucune crise politique ou rien du tout
ça a été une des bases un des piliers de
ma vie parce que ça m'a construit comme
un individu heureux épanoui équilibré
dans un pays formidable
c'est une base sur laquelle j'ai
construit le reste de ma vie j'ai eu la
chance ensuite d'aller faire des études
en europe j'ai eu la chance ensuite à 25
ans de me retrouver en californie en
tant qu'analyste dans un fonds
d'investissement en week end
un de mes amis m'invite à une retraite
de fonds d'investissement donc il faut
savoir que les fonds d'investissement
sont les sociétés qui finance
l'innovation dans la californie et la
plupart des grosses sociétés de
technologie que vous connaissez de
hewlett-packard à hotmail et skype tout
s'est soucié là ont été financés par des
fonds d'investissement ce sont des gens
qui leur ont fait confiance au moment
c'était les petites pousses
donc c'est un des points clés de la
capacité d'innovation des états unis et
je disais que pourrait inventer une
conviction que j'ai eu un week-end c'est
qu'il faut être capable de voir ce que
les autres ne voient pas il faut être
capable de changer de perspective
donc je me suis trouvé à 25 ans dans ces
environnements jeunes ivoiriens à 25 ans
dans un fonds d'investissement bien payé
dans un des meilleurs quartiers de san
francisco lego vous comprenez il a
tendance un peu à monter un peu je le
reconnais je me retrouve ce week-end là
une conférence ont parlé puis un moment
donné
il faut s'asseoir autour d'une table
donc je maintiens autour de la table à
ma droite il ya un monsieur chauffe des
petites lunettes l'air un peu stricte et
sérieux bon je sais pas je regarde à
gauche y en a un autre avec les cheveux
en bataille un peu la star californienne
donc on commence à discuter celui de
droite je vous remets ma carte de
musique qui me remet la sienne
partenaires à une tutelle in q tel mais
bon je ne sais pas qu'est ce que c'est
vous êtes dans un fond je dis moi je
suis un fonds qui est présent en asie en
france en europe et vous qu'est ce que
fait votre fonds et là il me regarde il
dit une tutelle celle fonde avec la cia
l'icwa et là j'apprends que les services
secrets américains financent chaque
année des start up technologiques pour
être capable dans leur mission d'avoir
un coup d'avancé en terme de technologie
en termes d' écoute en termes de
décryptage de ce système
donc les services de sécurité américains
financent des start-up premier choc
psychologique
mon voisin de gauche on discute je lui
donne ma carte et où il me dit ah oui je
m'appelle team drapper jadeyaoui et vous
faites quoi et là il me regarde en
disant mais c'est qui ce mec là qui sait
pas qui je suis je dit bon on dirait que
j'ai fait une connerie je vois tous les
regards autour de la table donc moi je
suis tranquille et où il ya revenez d'où
je dire moi je suis né en côte d'ivoire
j'ai fait mes études en france et est
maintenant je suis dans un fonds est dit
mais comment tu fais pour avoir fait un
tel parcours donc on discute on discute
et à un moment donné il se lève et j'ai
des amis qui dit mais tu es fou tu sais
pas qui c'est je dis ah non je sais pas
qui c'est et là j'apprends que ce
monsieur il a financé hotmail il a
financé et skype ensuite il a financé et
twitter il a financé tesla bref 23
sociétés qui ont plus d'un milliard de
dollars de capitalisation
je m'adressais à une des légendes
vivantes de la silicon valley ce
monsieur son père était le patron de usa
ex'im banque qui était la banque qu'à
financer l'expansion dans les années
70-80 de la plupart des grosses sociétés
américaines à l'international ce
monsieur son grand-père drapper premier
était sous secrétaire d'état à la
défense américain dans les années 40
vous savez quelle était sa
responsabilité le développement du plan
marshall de reconstruction de l'europe
je me trouvais donc moi jeune ingénieur
dont l'ego commencé à monter je me suis
assis je dis bon d'accord voilà un
monsieur comme ça depuis trois
générations
ces gens inventent
créé et construit ont bâti leur pays
pour l'amener à ce niveau là ce jour là
mon ego est revenu à des proportions
beaucoup plus raisonnable et ça m'a fait
du bien parce que le reste de ma
carrière j'ai toujours eu ce changement
de perspective de comprendre que oui
c'est vrai nous avons nos enjeux
personnels individuel on veut si tu n'as
pas de maison tu fais une maison si tu
as une maison tu avais une deuxième
si tu en as 2 si on veut des plus
grosses si on veut une en europe si on
veut unis si on veut une dans tel
endroit
mais quelque part la question aussi à un
moment donné c'est de dire quel est
l'impact
qu'est ce que tu as créé qu'est ce que
tu vas laisser quand tu vas partir donc
autre conviction
la première la prise de risque il faut
ouvrir de nouvelles portes et la seconde
il faut changer le perspective il faut
être capable de voir au delà de ce que
le on a devant ses yeux
au-delà de cela pour penser plus à quel
est l'impact qu'on veut avoir réinventé
la rti après donc ce parcours je suis
ensuite allé en france et je me suis
retrouvé à la rti
la question s'est posée était de dire ok
bon était directeur développement et
stratégie afrique pour canal dans un
grand groupe qui se déploie qui double
du chiffre d'affaires tous les trois ans
tu te retrouve maintenant dans une
société qui est en même temps une
administration publique qui est
extrêmement marqué politiquement se font
80% des ivoiriens vous dites rti pense
politiques iep ans j'aurais télévisé de
20 heures
donc la première étape a été de changer
de perspective
oui c'est vrai que c'est le journal
télévisé de 20 heures oui c'est vrai il
ça fait partie de notre mandat légal
à travers notre cahier des charges nous
devons faire la promotion des activités
du gouvernement
mais quelque part en tant qu'objet
économique qu'est ce que la rti latine
c'est ce qu'on appelle un marché me
fasse voyez quand je dis marchés bifaces
on se dit ah tiens on parle plus de joie
un téléviseur n'est plus dans
l'administration on est dans un concept
économique les marchés bifaces ce sont
des secteurs dans lequel une entreprise
à deux clients une télévision à deux
clients
j'ai une audience pour qui je dois faire
un programme de qualité pour qu'ils
soient capables de venir et j'ai des
clients qui sont des annonceurs qui
viennent en fonction du profil la
quantité de téléspectateurs que j'ai
donc c'est un concept d'économie et ya
tout un tas de stratégie qui se
développe
j'ai un copain de promotion aux roumains
qui actuellement est profane mighty
astaffort et arts ea
et harvard et dont la thèse et les
secteurs qu'ils développent sont ces
fameux marchés multifaces donc il faut
comprendre qu'un média c'est finalement
une entreprise et médias c'est une
entreprise à développer
donc l'enjeu a consisté à dire sorto de
la perspective on continuera d'avoir le
journal de 20h on continuera d'avoir un
certain nombre de ministres d'autorité
autres qui passe c'est vrai mais quelque
part nous sommes une entreprise et en
tant qu'entreprise nous avons des
produits des produits pour une phrase de
notre marché que sont les
téléspectateurs et des produits pour
l'autre face de marché que sont les
annonceurs et donc c'est ainsi que nous
avons commencé à renouveler notre offre
de produits
nous avons commencé à modifier notre
marketing notre commercialisation
nous avons commencé à restructurer en
termes de coûts renégocier pas mal de
nos contrats et grâce à cela nous avons
pu avoir des moyens pour pouvoir
investir et développer
c'est comme ça que vous voyez la tour
est penché il s'agissait simplement de
changer de perspective pour prendre
cette structure comme une société comme
une société qui se développe qu'on
restructure et qui peut obtenir des
résultats et se développer effectivement
trois ans pour ceux qui connaissent les
indicateurs économiques
l'ebitda a été multiplié par dix
l'ebitda c'est l'équivalent d'excédent
brut d'exploitation
donc en tant que modèle économique en
tant que structure économique
l'entreprise a été transformée grâce à
ce changement de perspective
bien sûr ce n'est pas que ce changement
sur ce qu'yves il ya eu l'un des points
clé ça a été les talents alors je suis
arrivé l'une des premières choses que
j'ai faites on aime les 600 cv on a
demandé à tous les collaborateurs de
donner leur cv les 600 cv ont été mis
dans une base de données et on a
commencé à fouiller ses bases de données
on s'est rendu compte qu'on avait des
chauffeurs qui avait les bac + 5 en
comptabilité
parce que vous savez qu'en côte d'ivoire
c'est difficile d'avoir du boulot
certains ont eu une occasion d'avoir un
boulot au lieu de rester à la maison ils
ont préféré le prendre en tant que
chauffeur alors qu'en fait ils avaient
les compétences plus pointu que cela
nous avions des gens qui étaient en
charge de gérer des éléments de stock
alors qu'ils avaient les formations de
direction photo par le passé donc une
partie du travail a constitué à
déplacez moon identifier les talents en
interne les repositionner où il fallait
pour pouvoir leur permettre de
d'apporter de la valeur au niveau de
l'entreprise
bien sûr en plus de ça il a fallu faire
appel à des talents extérieurs donc nous
sommes allés chercher des jeunes
ivoiriens présents en côte d'ivoire à
l'international qui ont chacun voulu
participer à cette aventure de
rénovation d'innovation de
transformation une fois que nous avons
commencé cette cette dynamique je me
suis souvenu de deux points importants
le premier c'est que en californie toute
société que vous rencontrez n'a qu'un
seul objectif c'est conquérir le monde
ce que notre boulot en tant que analyse
dans un fond c'était de recevoir des
entrepreneurs toute la journée vous avez
des gens dont l'objectif est de
conquérir le monde
la première étape c'est l'europe la
seconde étape c'est l'asie voire le
moyen-orient ils veulent conquérir le
monde donc l'international est au coeur
des stratégies donc dans quand on parle
de réinventer les codes et là je
m'adresse aux entrepreneurs à tous ceux
du monde des entreprises
il faut comprendre que le marché local
ne suffit pas vous pourrez faire des
choses sur le marché local
il faut une base bien entendu mais à un
moment donné il faut penser à attaquer
l'international si vous regardez toutes
les plus grandes sociétés au monde ce
sont des sociétés qui sont présentes à
l'international
parce qu'à un moment donné vous devez
développer pour améliorer votre offre et
quelque part tous ses coups que vous
déployez pour votre offre
le marché local pas suffire à contenir
cela donc la seconde réinvention qu'on a
fait après l'introduction de talent
après la refonte après les premiers
éléments a été de pousser
l'internationalisation de la rti cette
internationalisation et là plusieurs
niveaux d'abord elle est au niveau de la
diffusion
donc nous avons étendu notre signal
aujourd'hui nous sommes présents en
amérique du nord amérique latine en asie
en europe et sur toute l'afrique nous
avons mis en place une application
mobile qui présente aujourd'hui dans 24
pays
un ami me disait récemment écoute j'ai
vu l'imam de mon quartier à new york lui
aussi il utilise son application
ça m'a bien fait rire j'ai dit ben dis
donc c'est finalement la technologie est
capable de traverser tous les secteurs
de traverser et les gens qui ne sont pas
forcément
féru de technologie lorsqu'un service
les intéressent eh bien ils sont capable
d'adhérer à ce service donc nous avons
fait l'international ation de la
diffusion le second volet
d'internationalisation de en fait c'est
l'exploitation du contenu ivoiriens on
le sait tous depuis des dizaines
d'années la côte d'ivoire la côte
d'ivoire est un hub qui est qui attire
les talents culturels de nombreux pays
donc en tant que hub
ça veut dire que nous avons un contenu
qui intéresse au delà de nos frontières
et donc aujourd'hui nous sommes fiers de
dire que nous sommes présents sur de
nombreux continents
comme vous pouvez le voir sur la carte
nous avons des clients en afrique nous
avons des clients en europe
nous avons des clients à haïti le
dernier que nous venons d'avoir c'est la
malaisie donc ça ça a été le grand
plaisir de voir qu'une plateforme
digitale originaire de malaisie est venu
nous acheter du contenu donc cet
interdit cette exportation du contenu
ivoiriens nous permet aujourd'hui
d'avoir plus d'entrées pour pouvoir
financer encore plus de production
encore plus de qualité pour les
téléspectateurs
enfin le dernier élément une chose est
d'exporter son contenu mais quelque part
il faut aller à la rencontre du monde et
donc nous avons également décidé
d'externaliser la production
ça veut dire de ne pas nous contenter de
produire en côte d'ivoire d'aller à
l'international d'aller à la rencontre
du du monde pour pouvoir produire
également là bas nous avons donc
aujourd'hui les projets au nigeria
nous avons des projets en afrique du sud
je pars la semaine prochaine finaliser
les négociations avec la s abaisser pour
une coproduction avec eux nous avons des
projets en europe
nous avons des projets en inde avec itv
qui est un des plus gros acteurs le
numéro un je pense que les ivoiriens
connaissent bien la série salonique a
été très longtemps sur nos antennes et
bien ce groupe là est le numéro un en
inde aujourd'hui en termes de production
quelque part nous nous sommes ouverts à
ces acteurs là pour produire une série
qu ensemble
si la vidéo marche bien j'aimerais bien
qu'on montre quelques images
ils sont entrés ils viennent de finir de
tourner la première partie à dubaï et
nous allons les accueillir abidjan au
mois de décembre
pas de son
donc voilà c'est une série coproduite
entre la rt jesi tv
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc voilà notre tout dernier projet qui
est en train d'être fait il arrive en
descendre en difficulté qu'on va avoir
c'est que quand j'ai vu le cadre dans
lequel ils ont été on avait commencé à
visiter quelques villas mais je crois
qu'on a décidé de d'éliminer ces visas
là donc je crois qu'il ya un spécialiste
de l'architecturé je lui parlais tout à
l'heure ce que après ce qu'ils nous ont
montré la faut qu'on leur montre en côte
d'ivoire on est capable de faire
également de très belles choses et je je
compte sur toi merci à tous
[Applaudissements]